now so valiant I kind of wish McCain had
a better better route yeah he [ __ ] up
that Sarah Palin she was a dingdong and
that was preposterous yeah really
hey man and I would love to see a woman
in the White House it's not that what's
not yeah yeah no not that one she was
real no I take 10 Hillary Clinton I take
one and I don't want Hillary Clinton to
win I think she's ridiculously awful too
I think a lot of people really disliked
Hillary really disliked her they should
yeah she got a shitload of money from
banks she's completely full of [ __ ] she
didn't like gay marriage till 2013 she
wouldn't didn't agree with gay marriage
until 2013 like what are you a dinosaur
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with you why
would you even care cuz she's not real
then she doesn't she didn't care she
just was doing what she thought would
support her position politically she was
leaning right when Obama was leaning
more left and she was trying to center
herself as a or position herself as a
wiser choice for people who were unhappy
with the choices on the right but really
unhappy with Obama and like she was she
was a better option she's more sensible
she's a little more hawkish a little
more prone to go to war a little more
probe military or at least military
action but meanwhile just a puppet of
banks and just those people make [ __ ]
piles of money from speeches and there's
major problems with the Clinton
Foundation it's not even around anymore
I mean while she's doing all this meet
to talk her husband's a goddamn predator
yeah he's been a predator forever that I
think for women at least for me I was
like you're gonna stay with this Brawley
come on Nicola Winsky think she said
that Monica Lewinsky was a grown woman
and it wasn't an abuse of power get the
[ __ ] on she was 20 he was the president
twenty is you're a kid he was the
president there's no more powerful
person on earth if that's not an abuse
of power what is an abuse of power
you're saying and someone who works for
you and you run
the world I know dude I know and I get
it if I were 20 he was around what still
operating the Clinton Foundation but
didn't they shut down part of it
something shut look down Clinton
Foundation shuts down or cease
operations look that up because there
was some article that I read about it I
think for me just the whole stand by
your man thing no matter what it's just
so antiquated oh kinda just going back
to his Tommy fun stuff I better turn
them in for cash that's a terrible sight
oh dude yeah so it didn't shut down at
all nothing
in fact checked out of work hmm Google a
story though
see if there's a Google Clinton
Foundation that these baseless claims
are made up by a self-described
satirical website oh so they're not did
it reduce operations or anything there's
another thing that says from 2017 they
shut down the Clinton Global Initiative
but that was the thing it was right
after the election which is 2016 that's
what I had read that after the election
after it was all over I don't know
either way the Clinton Foundation's
super sketch one of the reasons that
super sketches a lot of people that
donate there's just a lot of weird [ __ ]
going on with donators and then them
doing speeches for these huge
organizations like banks getting paid
hundreds of thousands dollars to some
boring a speech which is essentially a
bribe right those people aren't pumped
to see her talk I don't think any of
these people are legit I mean no Obama's
done a lot of it too he's done a lot of
those paid speeches you get hundreds of
thousands of dollars to talk but I guess
I mean look I don't want to [ __ ] get
into it but isn't that why people love
Trump because he's outside of the whole
system theoretically oh here goes end of
an era the Clinton Global Initiative
shuts down yeah
and of an error not an error errr
when they asked him there was a there
was an interview where they asked him
about Monica Lewinsky like to you or an
apology he's like well anybody who
thinks I got that clean it's crazy
no I caught that cost me millions of
dollars I left the White House in debt
and all this that's not what anybody
asked he [ __ ] sociopath I think she
deserves an apology because he never
spoke to her of course
and meanwhile she was what one of the
first people to be publicly shamed yes
for something of this nature this is a
huge scandal and this is back before you
know the 24-hour news cycle really right
yeah that stuck forever forever for this
poor woman's life was over done this day
done Monica Lewinsky synonymous with
dick-sucker
that's it isn't that [ __ ] up glad you
said it not me
this poor girl makes one mistake as a 20
year old yeah and now her whole life is
this scandal do you remember there was a
town hall thing that did on HBO many
years later where she was talking to a
group of people about the the president
and about the whole situation and in the
middle like you know people had to ask
questions and talk to her and one guy
goes you know it just seems to me like
you're just milking this for attention
like why even still talking about this
but and she was like and he was like why
are you still talking about this this is
so horrific like why why do you keep
bringing this up like what does she want
to do who imagine most again what is she
supposed to do but imagine being that
person who was 20 years old so
essentially you're a kid and then the
whole world knows she sucked the
president's dick so everywhere you go
people like you such the president she
said that it sticks like tar that was
her description that the shame sticks to
you like tar I believe it and what about
Marilyn Monroe was she second Kennedy
everybody everybody's Robert and Bobby
in Jack but there's no evidence I guess
there was no dress there was no why was
that not know the world was a different
place but DNA air quotes died right they
killed that [ __ ] you think so hundred
percent
hundred percent apparently she was all
yappity-yap yeah and she's getting older
and then we wanted a bang or anymore
[Laughter]